on the bound for the padres is to nelson
lamet should be an exciting night really
anxious to see the right-hander toe the
slab 28 year old making his sixth start
last time out through 72 pitches
maybe about 85 tonight stretch him out a
little bit he went four innings last
time against the chicago cubs at wrigley
field
one run ball in that outing he's only
surrendered one home run
sure he's only going 18 innings but
still throwing the ball really really
well and a swing and a missed strike
three so the nelson begins this game the
way he begins so many with a strikeout
and one away in the top of the first one
now base is empty for chris bryant he's
getting the start in center field today
why not take in on the inside corner at
the knees strike three called back to
back gaze for lament to open up this
game peterson and bryant go down and
confess who was leading off in last
night's game now batson and that is
rifled foul down the right side
oh yeah nice one-handed
bevy in the other oh
yeah old friend zach davies on the mound
for the cubs 28 year old making his 13th
start 0-2 with a 6-7-5 and six starts on
the road
one out fans still at first that brings
up jake cronenworth a swing in a line
drive caught double play sogar the
second baseman loving the liner flip the
torrizzo fam wandered off the bag it's a
4-3 double play on the line out so lumet
issues a one-out walk here in the second
inning puts a man aboard for the
switch-hitting alcantara now contrast
swings and misses throw to first and
hayward gets picked off
a double play a most unusual double play
david ross says hold the phone we're
going to make sure that uh the call was
right before we
just let it slide
right hand
used to be there before the tag yeah i
got safe
safe at first base so it has been
overturned he's one of the best bunters
among pitchers in the national league
but that is uh not in play of course
you're leading off the inning davies
hits this one really well out to left
fam is racing towards the corner he gets
there to make a running catch
tommy pham covering all kinds of ground
making the play and out number one i'll
tell you what i did not think tommy pham
was going to get anywhere close to this
where he was positioned
that's a 10 uber ride
nice
here's wilson contreras wilson has
caught more innings than any catcher in
big league ball swung on hit in the air
to left field this ball's got a chance
gone
upper deck in left field cubs lead one
to nothing
get out the tape measure for wilson
contreras
cubs lead one to nothing now the ball's
not carrying in san diego unless you hit
it like that
that ball was crushed it's a slider
and it's out over the plate and willie
did not miss it at all he
crushes this ball
to left field and as you said pat upper
deck about three rows deep in the second
deck in san diego wow
one down in the fourth inning jake's
second look at zach davies tonight
popped up
shallow left over toward the line long
run peterson and he makes a nice running
tap crossing the foul line
and then gently
the lighting with the sidewall almost
flipped into the stand but
able to make the catch it's a good pitch
right in on his hand on the inside part
of the plate jam shot one that looked
like he could fall in
drops able to get over there but zach
has just been found in the strike zone
two down here in the fourth inning and
here is fernando
for the second time tonight broken bat
flare out towards center and that will
get down for a base hit the first of the
night for the padres
as always tatis takes a very aggressive
turn around first base but bryant was
there to pick up the ball send it back
to the infield two out single in the
fourth this is so baseball his first hit
bat squares up a baseball hits it as
hard as you can
it's a now this one
his bat dies a soldier and he gets a
knock bottom of the order due up here
against nelson lament as denelson looks
to record it out in the fifth inning for
the first time since last season as he
strikes out
altontra that is five strikeouts for
lament one down here in the fifth he's
got the look as if saying to the hitters
try and hit this
bring it on if i locate it no chance
zach davies has been cruising along he's
given up just one hit over the first
four innings swung on a miss a breaking
ball that myers could not make contact
with run away here in the fifth inning
it'll bring up jerickson profile swing
did he go appeal to third yes he did vic
carapaza rings him up back-to-back
strikeouts and there's two outs they
bring up the catcher webster rebounds
hits one on the ground down the third
base line fair ball wisdom backhand
throw to first
in time
what a play by patrick wisdom at the hot
corner side retired so tonight five
innings a season high
his 77 pitches a season high and the six
strikeouts same now the cubs in business
two men on nobody out and anthony rizzo
coming up rizzo lines one toward right
center field that's a base hit it goes
all the way to the wall this is gonna
drive in one i think it's gonna drive in
two here comes bryant to the plate to
score a two-run double anthony rizzo
cubs lead three-nothing jericks and
profile took a bad angle there and that
ball was hit really hard and it cubs add
two and they're up three-nothing
man at third with one away cubs lead
three-nothing wisdom was the national
league player of the week last week by
hitting six homers in seven games
patrick wisdom
pulls one to left
and the cubs enjoying a five nothing
lead
a line smash to left it left the park in
a hurry and the cubs lead by a high five
and that's exactly what patrick is going
to receive in the cubs dugout high fives
all around
rizzo steps in back to two-run double
his last time let's see if he can drive
in peterson he hits one in the air to
left center pretty well hit back to the
wall it's got a chance gone
rizzo and opposite field homer into left
left center and the cubs now have opened
up a seven to nothing lead towering
opposite field glass for anthony so
hassan kim will be coming up his first
at-bat of the night after entering the
game as a defensive replacement swung on
in the air down the left field line that
is going to get down peterson cuts it
off before it gets to the corner fam is
scored cronenworth on his way to third
kim into second base sliding with a
double
so the padres on the board here in the
bottom of the ninth inning there will be
no shutout
hassan kim rbi two bagger seven to one
chicago to myers swaying in a mouse it's
all over the cubs win the ball game
7-1 the final lots of pump fans happy
here in san diego tonight